so lieben Millionen Deutsche
Griechenland malerische Küsten weiße
Strände und türkis-blaues Meer der
Tourismus ist mit Abstand wichtigste
Wirtschaftszweig neben den Hoteliers
warten vor allem Studierende auf den
Saisonstart weil sie einen Job suchen
und Geld verdienen müssen so auch
Konstantina petraki die 21-Jährige
studiert Management in Thessaloniki und
arbeitet hier für den Mindestlohn von
780 €
. alle Studenten haben finanzielle
Probleme und suchen Arbeit im Tourismus
sowie auch ich jetzt hier ich arbeite in
der Sommersaison und im Winter gehe ich
zu den Vorlesungen ich versuche mein
Studium unter einen Hut zu bringen mit
der Sommersaison dem Tourismus
arbeiten wo andere Urlaub machen doch
oft bleibt der Tourismus auch nach dem
teuren Studienabschluss die einzige
zuverlässige Einkommensquelle und genau
das ist das Problem
[Musik]
ich will wissen welche Perspektiven
haben junge Leute in Griechenland was
erwarten Sie vor der Wahl am Sonntag und
wie blicken sie in die Zukunft zu Besuch
in einer Studenten-WG in Thessaloniki
die Studierenden hier sind im doppelten
Wahlkampf denn auch an ihrer Uni finden
gerade Studierenden Wahlen statt
Stereos Gregorio ist 23 und hat sich
nach dem Abitur für ein BWL-Studium
entschieden er sympatisiert mit den
Linken und lehnt den Kurs der Regierung
ab
wenn mir jemand erzählen will dass er in
den vergangenen vier Jahren unter einer
neoliberalen Regierung das Gefühl hatte
dass seine persönlichen Freiheiten
erweitert worden sind dann weiß ich
nicht was ich ihm antworten soll
vor allem aber protestieren sie hier
gegen die gestiegenen
Lebenshaltungskosten
wir erleben wie die Medien täglich im
wahrsten Sinne des Wortes die Regierung
und ihre Erfolge beweihräuchern während
wir deren Konsequenzen am eigenen Leib
spüren
auf ihre Plakate malen sie runter mit
den Preisen hoch mit den Löhnen vor
allem Miete und Energie sind für sie
fast unbezahlbar geworden
als Studentin bin ich gezwungen riesige
Summen aufzubringen vor allem für die
Unterkunft
die Mieten hier in der Stadt sind
unheimlich gestiegen gerade in den
letzten zwei Jahren
sie wohnt noch bei den Eltern und
arbeitet nebenher um sich das Studium
finanzieren zu können ihre Generation
ist aufgewachsen in einem Land im
krisenmodus Staatsschuldenkrise
corona-krise Energiekrise und Inflation
wir sind in Thessaloniki der
zweitgrößten Stadt Griechenlands
wirtschaftliches und kulturelles Zentrum
der nordgriechischen Region Mazedonien
trotzdem Boomtown Image liegt die
Arbeitslosigkeit bei über 30% und auf
der Stadt lastet die Erinnerung an eine
Tragödie der Bahnhof von Thessaloniki
ist ein Ort der Trauer und der Wut hier
warteten am 28 Februar viele Freunde und
Familien vergebens auf ihre Angehörigen
57 Menschen starben beim größten
Zugunglück in der Geschichte des Landes
in tempi darunter viele junge Leute die
zum Studium nach Thessaloniki wollten
es kam landesweit zu Demonstrationen
gegen die Regierung und auch für die
Studierenden der Universität Mazedonien
in Thessaloniki bedeutete das Unglück
eine Zäsur
die Tragödie von Tempi bei der dutzende
junge Menschen starben hat nicht bloß
die Probleme der regierungskultur
aufgezeigt
die kannten wir alle nämlich mangelnde
Transparenz und einen klientelstand
wurde auch eine tiefgreifende
Inkompetenz sogar bei einfachen
Verwaltungsfragen
beim Wahlkampf an der Hochschule treffe
ich Stereos Gregorio wieder er beklagt
eine Vetter in Wirtschaft die schon an
der Uni beginne und kritisiert die
schlechten Zukunftsperspektiven für
seine Generation
um eine Familie zu gründen braucht man
ja wohl eine Wohnung eine feste Arbeit
ein festes Einkommen
was von diesen drei Dingen kann uns die
griechische Realität bieten
der 25-Jährige Wirtschaftsstudent
Kiriakos kasakos ist da ganz anderer
Meinung er ist ein Fan von
Regierungschef mit sotakis von der
Partei näher Demokratie dessen
Wirtschaftsliberaler Kurs und sein
Ansehen auf internationaler Bühne
imponieren ihm wenn sie wir denken dass
die Regierung das besser gemeistert hat
als man das überhaupt erwarten konnte
dass auch wir von ihrer Effektivität
überrascht waren
wir jungen Leute die wir im Land bleiben
und etwas dafür tun wollen sind der
Meinung dass dafür die Unterstützung der
näher Demokratia absolut notwendig ist
wenn wir in unserem Land eine Zukunft
haben wollen
und so verweist Ministerpräsident
Kiriakos mit syrtakis in seinem
Wahlkampf vor allem auf wirtschaftliche
Erfolgszahlen Griechenland so seine
Message habe sich in Europa vom
Sorgenkind zum Musterschüler entwickelt
wie zur Tag ist führt mit seiner Partei
näher Demokratia die Umfragen an ein
veritabler Abhörskandal und letztlich
auch das Zugunglück haben ihm einen
Dämpfer verpasst gegen ihn tritt sein
Amtsvorgängers an der verspricht mit
seiner sirizerpartei vor allem mehr
sozialen Ausgleich für einen
Regierungswechsel reicht es laut
aktuellen Umfragen allerdings nur wenn
er eine Koalition aus
unterschiedlichsten Parteien
zusammenbringt schwierige
Konstellationen sind zu erwarten ein
zweiter Wahlgang schon jetzt
wahrscheinlich
erstmal sind die jungen Griechen ab 17
wahlberechtigt und so könnte es ganz
besonders auf ihre Wahlbeteiligung
ankommen
einmal im Jahr findet in Thessaloniki
ein Stück Zukunft statt auf der Tech
Saloniki werben IT-Firmen um eine
seltene Spezies junge gut ausgebildete
InformatikerInnen Maria ramo organisiert
die Jobbörse und erzählt mir dass die
aufstrebende Branche in Thessaloniki
Händeringen Fachkräfte sucht
ich persönlich sehe etwas besorgt in die
Zukunft und zwar deswegen weil ich nicht
weiß ob wir alle freien Stellen in der
Branche werden besetzen können
viele der Studierenden haben allerdings
das Vertrauen in ihr Land und die
Politik verloren so oft schon wurde
ihnen eine bessere Zukunft versprochen
ich möchte eigentlich nicht in
Griechenland bleiben ich habe einige
meiner studentenjahre damit verbracht
mir hier eine Zukunft aufzubauen aber
ich sehe dass ich im Ausland sehr viel
bessere Chancen habe die Mühe die ich
hier investiert habe zu nutzen und ein
besseres Leben zu führen
gehen oder bleiben vieles wird davon
abhängen ob die Politik bei der jungen
Generation Vertrauen zurückgewinnen kann
egal welche Partei am Ende von liegt bei
den Parlamentswahlen in Griechenland